HIS FAMILY HOPES THAT A DRUG
MIGHT BE THE CURE FOR JACK
ALLARD.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, THANK YOU.
ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
TONIGHT.
SO YOU HEARD WITH THE PRESIDENT
SAID TODAY.
HE TALKED ABOUT EASTER, WANTING
TO GET THINGS OPENED.
HE SAID WE HAVE TO GO BACK MUCH
SOONER THAN PEOPLE THOUGHT.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> WELL, I THINK, HOPEFULLY WE
CAN DO IT BEFORE EASTER, BUT
IT’S GOT TO BE CONDITIONED.
I WANT TO GET OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN, BUT IF THE GENERALS
TELL ME WE WILL GET ATTACKED IF
WE GET OUT TOO SOON, I WON’T GET
OUT.
TO THE PRESIDENT, YOU ARE RIGHT
TO WANT TO JUMP-START THE
ECONOMY, BUT DON’T TRY TO CREATE
AN ECONOMIC BUMP THAT LEADS TO A
SPIKE IN THE VIRUS.
OUR GOAL IS TO DESTROY THE
VIRUS.
SO ANY DECISION TO OPEN UP THE
ECONOMY BASED ON AGE OR REASON
NEEDS TO BE SCIENTIFICALLY
BLESSED BY THE EXPERTS.
ANY PRESIDENT WHO TURNS DOWN
SOUND ADVICE DURING A WAR
USUALLY REGRETS IT.
SO MY GOAL IS TO TURN ON THE
ECONOMY, BUT IT’S GOT TO BE
CONDITIONED SPACE.
IF THE DATA SUPPORTS IT, I’M FOR
IT.
IF IT DOESN’T, I’M AGAINST IT.
AND I WILL JUST SAY THIS, THAT
MOST AMERICANS HEARD FROM
DR. BIRX AND DR. FAUCI THAT IT
WAS NOT SAFE TO GO BACK TO WORK,
NO MATTER WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID, MOST WOULD NOT GO BACK TO
WORK.
>> Martha: YEAH.
DESPITE WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SAYING, DR. FAUCI OUT OF HIS WAY
SEVERAL TIMES TODAY TO SAY THAT
THE PRESIDENT DOES LISTEN TO HIS
ADVICE.
>> HE DOES.
>> Martha: AND THAT HE FELT
THAT SHE FELT IT WAS DIVISIVE TO
SUGGEST, TO TRY TO PIT THEM
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
IT DOESN’T REALLY HELP ANYBODY.
IN THIS COUNTRY.
BUT DO YOU FEEL CONFIDENT, YOU
KNOW THE PRESIDENT WELL AND TALK
TO HIM A LOT, THAT HE WILL
LISTEN TO THEIR ADVICE ON THIS?
>> YEAH, I AM VERY CONFIDENT HE
WILL BECAUSE THIS PRESIDENT HAS
THE BEST MEDICAL TEAM AROUND
HIM.
THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS DONE A
WONDERFUL JOB.
AND YOU ARE RIGHT,
MR. PRESIDENT, TO WANT TO TURN
BACK ON THE ECONOMY, BUT WE’VE
GOT TO DO IT SMARTLY.
I’M HERE IS WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST
SUGGEST.
DR. FAUCI SAID, BASED ON THE
DATA, THEY MAY BE REGIONS THAT
WE CAN OPEN UP.
THERE MAY BE DEMOGRAPHICS,
YOUNGER PEOPLE MAY BE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO WORK WITHOUT A LOT OF
RISK, BUT I WOULD MAKE MY
DECISIONS BASED ON MY MEDICAL
EXPERTS.
THE GOAL IS TO OPEN UP THE
ECONOMY, BUT IT NEEDS TO BE
CONDITIONED SPACE.
THE NUMBER ONE DECISION THE
PRESIDENT MADE SMARTLY WAS TO
STOP TRAVEL FROM CHINA EARLY ON.
ONLY GOD KNOWS HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE ALIVE TODAY BECAUSE HE
STOPPED TRAVEL FROM CHINA.
DON’T UNDERCUT THAT DECISION BY
WANTING TO OPEN UP THE ECONOMY
TO QUICK.
IT’S GOT TO BE BASED ON SOUND
SCIENCE.
>> Martha: YEAH.
ALL RIGHT, LET’S TURN TO THE
BILL ON CAPITOL HILL, THE SENATE
BILL TONIGHT.
WHERE DOES IT STAND?
IS IT THE RIGHT TO BILL?
I KNOW OBVIOUSLY THERE IS A
MODEL PUSH TO GET IT DONE, BUT
IT NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING
THAT IS EFFECTIVE, AND WHAT ARE
THE PROBLEMS RIGHT NOW, AS YOU
SEE IT, FOR TONIGHT?
>> WELL, HE DOESN’T NEED TO BE
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
THIS BILL HAD A BUNCH OF JUNK IN
IT THAT WAS JUST A LIBERAL WISH
LIST.
I THINK MOST OF IT IS OUT.
MITCH McCONNELL SAID WE ARE
INSIDE THE 2-YARD LINE, BUT
HERE’S THE PROBLEM: THERE ARE 20
PEOPLE PLAYING DEFENSE, ALL KIND
OF SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS
TRYING TO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE,
TRYING TO SAY NO TO THIS, NO TO
THAT.
HERE IS WHAT I SAY.
IF WE DON’T HAVE A BILL IN THE
NEXT 48 HOURS, EVERY MEMBER AND
EVERY STAFF PERSON OUT HERE
SHOULD LOSE THEIR PAY AND THEIR
BENEFITS UNTIL HE PASSED THE
BILL.
MARTHA McSALLY HAS LEGISLATION
TO DO THAT.
IF WE DON’T HAVE A BILL IN THE
NEXT 48 HOURS, I GO BEFORE THE
SENATE AND MAKE THEM CONSENT
REQUEST TO CUT OUR PAY AND
BENEFITS UNTIL WE PASSED ONE.
I AM HOPEFUL, BUT I’VE BEEN
HOPEFUL FOR THE LAST 48 HOURS.
PASS THE DAMN BILL.
PEOPLE OUT OF WORK AND NEED A
PAYCHECK.
THE DOCTORS AND NURSES ARE UNDER
SIEGE AND THE MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
SMALL BUSINESSES UP AND PUT OUT
OF BUSINESS, LET’S GET THEM
ASSISTANCE.
ENOUGH ALREADY, PAST THE DAMN
BILL.
>> Martha: WHAT DO YOU THINK
IS REASONABLE, IN TERMS OF THE
TIMELINE?
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO SEE THE
VOTE --
>> TONIGHT.
>> Martha: YOU BELIEVE THE
BILL WILL PASS TO MAKE THEM
SENATE?
>> IF IT DOESN’T PASS TONIGHT,
THERE IS GOOD REASON.
THERE IS NO GOOD REASON LEFT TO
DENY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
RELIEF THEY NEED.
EVERY RESTAURANT AND BAR IN
SOUTH CAROLINA IS CLOSED.
AS LONG AS YOU CAN’T CONQUER
GREAT WITH TEN PEOPLE OR MORE,
THE ENTIRE ECONOMY IS SHUT
DOWN, SO PEOPLE NEED A PAYCHECK.
THEY NEED TO HAVE BURDENS TAKEN
OFF THEM.
THEIR STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS
DEFERRED.
THERE ARE SO MANY GOOD THINGS IN
THIS BILL, THERE’S $2 TRILLION.
IT IS VERY GENEROUS, AND WAS
HOLDING THIS BILL UP, SPECIAL
INTEREST POLITICS.
IF THE NEXT 48 HOURS, WE DO NOT
PASS THIS BILL, EVERYBODY IN THE
COUNTRY SHOULD CUT OFF OUR PAY.
>> Martha: WELL, I’M SURE A
LOT OF FOLKS WOULD HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH THAT, AND DO WANT
TO SEE A RESOLUTION HERE.
THAT’S THE BEST THING FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SENATOR RONNIE IS IN QUARANTINE.
A NUMBER OF SENATORS ARE IN
QUARANTINE.
SHOULD MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE AND
SENATE BE ABLE TO VOTE GIVEN THE
EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES, REMOTELY?
>> YEAH, WE ARE IN A WAR.
WE ARE IN A 2-FRONT WORE.
A WAR AGAINST THE VIRUS.
AND HERE’S WHAT I WOULD SAY,
WATCH WHAT’S HAPPENING IN
NEW YORK.
IF YOU WANT THAT MOVIE TO COME
TO YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD?
I’M ALL FOR TRYING TO JUMP-START
THE ECONOMY, BUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN NEW YORK COULD COME
TO SOUTH CAROLINA OR ANY OTHER
PLACE IF WE REALLY DON’T WATCH
IT HERE.
SO HERE IS MY HOPE, IS THAT WE
CAN PASS THIS BILL, WHICH WILL
PUT MONEY IN THE ECONOMY, BUY
TIME, TAKE FEAR AND BURDENS OFF
OF PEOPLE, AND WE CAN FOCUS ON
KILLING THE VIRUS.
WE ARE AT WAR WITH THIS VIRUS.
I WANT TO VOMIT AND KILL IT.
YOU STARVE IT BY HAVING SOCIAL
DISTANCING TO ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE NOT FOLLOWING GUIDELINES,
YOU.
WE BOMB IT BY HAVING THERAPIES
TO MAKE IT LESS LETHAL, AND YOU
KILLED IT WITH A VACCINE.
WHEN WILL WE TURN THE CORNER?
WHEN THERE ARE LESS AFFECTIONS,
THERAPIES THAT WORK, NOT JUST
TALKED ABOUT ON TV, AND WHEN
THAT IS ON THE HORIZON, THAT IS